notice something else though because  this is very revealing notice what the  left is not concerned about they're not  concerned that they are going to be  banned from Twitter now or that they're  going to be targeted the way that  Twitter has targeted the right they're  not worried about that because they know  that's not going to happen they know  that nobody on the right even wants that  I don't want that I don't want it  actually I would not want I mean if it  happens it happens but I don't want  Twitter to drive left this off the  platform and ban them because then  Twitter becomes a an echo chamber what's  the fun of that now that we can speak  basic truths on Twitter especially basic  biological truths I want the left to be  there I want them to be there and I want  them to be exposed to it